January 1998 Saddam Hussein has expelled
UN weapons inspectors and the United
States is threatening military action US
forces prepare for deployment
February 3rd while the battle of nerves
continues in Iraq Defense Department
security systems report an attempted
break-in to computers at Andrews Air
Force Base over the next two weeks
Pentagon security experts detect similar
assaults on military systems across the
country the intrusions seem to be
coordinated and they target computer
systems at the heart of the military
buildup damage to these systems could
halt the flow of Transportation
personnel and medical supplies it
certainly was given its timing in
concert with our military actions
against Iraq a wake-up call for many of
our leaders both uniformed and otherwise
and our governments that this is
potentially a very major threat to our
ability to execute our missions we do an
awful lot of work by email and through
unclassified the transmission of
deployment information and again if you
take one part of that machine and a
disable it you've got a real problem
trying to make a deployment operation
take place although the precise origin
and purpose of these attacks is unknown
Washington fears the worst a joint task
force is hastily assembled bringing
together personnel from the FBI various
military services and members of the
intelligence community so obviously
people were worried that this might be
an information warfare based attack or
some sort of attack designed to disrupt
US responses to problems in Iraq the
intruders are targeting computers that
use the Sun Solaris 2.4 or 2.6 operating
system exploiting a vulnerability common
among UNIX systems that can give hackers
an easy route in although this flaw in
the system and the software necessary to
fix it have been publicized since
December pentagon computer experts
haven't focused on the potential
backdoor into their systems
obviously hackers have
because of the common vulnerability
linking them
the FBI dubs its investigation of the
DoD intrusions solar sunrise
Friday February 6th more than 2,000
Marines are sent to the Gulf while the
search for a diplomatic solution
continues as the military stakes
continue to rise the investigation in
Washington is also gaining urgency
investigators tracing the attacks find
the cyber trail leads through a number
of foreign countries including Iraq's
Gulf neighbor the United Arab Emirates
the first priorities were to exchange
information because we have a lot of
different entities and determine what
scope of intrusion happened to the
different systems were their secret
systems were the unclassified systems
what were the significance of these
computer systems and can we tie it into
any sort of attack one of the first
things we did was caution everyone
involved that we've been down this road
before and where an attack seems to be
coming from and where an attack is
actually coming from maybe two different
things
investigators track the intrusions back
to their points of entry and find
they've been routed through a variety of
internet service providers or ISPs many
of these points of entry are University
sites where security is typically less
common pass through sites used by
hackers but at least two of the pass
through sites seem to deserve a closer
look sonic met a commercial ISP in
California and a near net in the United
Emirates one of the few electronic
gateways into Iraq while a mere net
itself is beyond the reach of US law
enforcement
it shows repeated links to a site that
is not maroon comm a webpage posting
service in College Station Texas without
its owner's knowledge the site is being
used as a hackers launching platform to
a wide variety of sites this hackers
country of origin Israel
with the permission of marooned comms
operator agents begin consensual
monitoring of all traffic in and out of
the network they soon find multiple
connections to military sites and
hacking activity that fits the pattern
of the solar sunrise break-ins but the
basic mystery remains
who is the Israeli intruder and what
does he want
meanwhile a parallel investigation is
following the trail of files stolen for
military sites the most tantalizing lead
a collection of account names and
passwords stolen from Andrews Air Force
Base and transferred to Sonic dotnet an
isp in Santa Rosa California the
intruder has apparently stashed his
stolen information at sonic net if he
comes back to examine it investigators
will be waiting when FBI agents from the
San Francisco field office contact sonic
net they get an unexpected break during
the same period as the initial attacks
on military sites system managers at
Sonic dotnet received complaints about
hacking assaults on Harvard and MIT
launched through their site they have
already identified the to hackers
responsible for those attacks local high
school kids whose screen names are Matt
and Stimpy
just four days after the first meeting
of the task force in Washington
investigators in California are set up
to track transmissions from sonic net to
known military sites this quickly
reveals connections to Andrews Air Force
Base initiated by Stimpy
February 13th support troops from
Andrews depart for the Gulf that same
day investigators in California receive
legal authority to increase their
surveillance of the two teenagers
Internet accounts under this new legal
authorization investigators can take
intercepted Internet traffic and
actually reconstruct the hackers online
sessions concern for the security of its
own network sonic net is also monitoring
these accounts their combined efforts
yield a critical lead and Internet Relay
Chat between math and someone who seems
to be teaching him the art of hacking a
more experienced computer guru with the
screen name analyzing as investigators
follow the electronic trail of Mac's
mentor they find that analyzers entry
point to the Internet is an ISP in
Israel suddenly the two parallel tracks
of the investigation begin to converge
he's analyzer the same Israeli hacker
who used maroon comm as his gateway to
US military sites February 23rd 1998 un
secretary-general kofi annan
negotiates a renewal of arms inspections
with saddam hussein in a matter of days
Washington agrees to the deal tensions
in the Gulf begin to relax but on
February 25th a new crisis strikes the
solar sunrise investigation the media
makes the story public well once the
case became public a lot of thoughts
came across her mind the first one in
particular up in California was to get
to the sites as soon as possible
if the teenagers here the investigation
before search warrants are served they
can erase all evidence of their crimes
racing against the clock investigators
from a wide range of task force agencies
converge on a suburb of San Francisco
they reached the to hackers homes at
6:30 p.m. Pacific time the same day the
story hits the press when the
investigators got to the homes what they
found were computers that were online
the individuals were online in chat
channels as the investigators entered
the homes both teens are interviewed in
their homes and both admit to breaking
into DoD computers after some initial
hesitation Mack tells investigators what
he knows about his teacher analyzing it
seems the kingpin of this hacking
assault on the US government is an 18
year old from Israel a week after the
California searches a defiant analyzer
gives a cyber interview to anti online a
web-based forum for hackers he takes
credit for the Pentagon intrusions and
for teaching Mac & stimpy their hacking
techniques to prove his claims he gives
a live hacking demonstration breaking
into a military site during the
interview and in an online dialogue with
anteye on lines reporter JP he offers
chilling insight into his motives
analyzers commitment to chaos is real
investigators recognize his screen name
from a number of other pending cases of
computer assault but no one knows his
true identity pooling their leads the
task force solves this final puzzle
armed with analyzers name and address
they take the case against him to
Israeli authorities one of the things
that solar sunrise demonstrated was that
in cyberspace the the cliche that that
cyberspace knows no boundaries is
absolutely true and that we therefore in
many investigations have to work closely
with our foreign counterparts because
hackers might go through several
different foreign countries on their way
to victims in the US with the help of
Israeli law enforcement the solar
sunrise team confronts analyzer
investigators searched his home and
under questioning he admits his role in
the hacking trails they've identified
this confession is only the tip of the
iceberg
forensic analysis of analyzers computer
equipment indicates he may have hacked
into more than 500 networks
one year later analyzer is indicted in
Israel on charges of computer crime
prosecution is still pending in
California
both teams plead guilty to violations of
Federal Computer Fraud and wiretapping
laws both boys are fined and sentenced
to three years of probation with 100
hours of community service they force it
their computers and are barred from
accessing the internet without adult
supervision as juveniles their legal
punishment is relatively light but this
youthful escapade may haunt them in
other ways they're applying for jobs and
they might of course want one in the
computer security field when their
employer asks them if they've ever been
arrested or convicted or involved in any
computer abuse it may have a lasting
consequence and their ability to get
employment in their area of choice IBM
would never consider hiring a reformed
hacker it would be like hiring a burglar
to institute a burglar system on your
house you wouldn't do it in the end the
solar sunrise invasions of military
sites proved to be purely recreational
but though no hostile government or
group was behind these intrusions the
case clearly demonstrates the
vulnerability of the nation's complex
information systems to terrorists
assault all of our plans to prepare for
a warfare in the 21st century depend
upon our use and leverage of information
technology to make our make our forces
more effective the tools are widely
available they are at minimal cost all
you need to have
as a desktop or a laptop computer and a
modem connection and you are in business
as a hacker a recent DoD study found
that Defense Department computers were
attacked a quarter of a million times in
a single year at least a dozen countries
are known to be funding extensive
information warfare programs but the
danger extends far beyond strictly
military targets as the Information Age
advances further we're finding that more
and more government agencies private
sector companies and individuals really
are relying on information technology as
a regular part of their daily lives and
daily operations building on the working
partnerships forged by the solar sunrise
task force n IPC is an interagency
effort combining the personnel and
resources of the FBI Treasury and energy
departments the Department of Defense
and the intelligence community to
protect the nation's electronically
vulnerable infrastructures the basic
mission of the NI PC is to coordinate
the government's activities that are
directed at detecting preventing warning
of and responding to cyber intrusions
particularly those directed at critical
infrastructures electronic attacks
creates special problems the evidence is
fleeting the cost of entry is extremely
low and computer criminals cross
national borders much faster than law
enforcement can but the need for
coordination isn't limited to
governmental players whether it's the
telecommunication system the banking and
finance sector that the transportation
sector or the energy sector all these
things are privately owned and operated
and that means that in order for us to
understand those systems what the
vulnerabilities are what the threats are
to those systems we need to have a
really close partnership with the owners
and operators of those systems for a
long time corporate America said well
we've never been had this isn't a
problem but survey after survey
shows us that the numbers are going up
in recent national surveys of corporate
information security professionals more
than half the companies responded
reported frequent internet attacks and
problems with unauthorized access by
company insiders more than a quarter
reported theft of proprietary
information estimates of annual
corporate losses from computer security
breaches run from 100 million to 300
billion dollars the types of information
that a hacker can get in in a computer
system could be sensitive proprietary
information to a company the jewels of a
company anybody that thinks that their
corporation doesn't have trade secrets
that are vulnerable it just doesn't
understand the problem drawing on it's
unique access to national intelligence
and law enforcement information n IPC is
developing an overview of cyber threats
no private sector company could create
alone law enforcement has tremendous
resources available to assist us in
protecting ourselves subpoena powers
search warrants the ability to track a a
hacker to its point of origin so we use
law enforcement more readily now than we
used to what's different now from five
or especially ten years ago is that to
be a successful hacker nowadays you
don't need to be a savvy sophisticated
highly educated computer scientist who
writes his own exploits and attacks
scripts and figures out after a lot of
work and background investigation into
his target figured out how to go after
that system but danger is real teenage
hackers have already interrupted
air-traffic control at an airport in
Massachusetts and disrupted 9-1-1
emergency services in Florida
imagine similar tools in the hands of a
hostile government or terrorist group
the corporate America has to do is when
their attack they need to contact law
enforcement immediately they need to
start turning on their audit trails and
need to start capturing keystrokes they
have
to respond in a responsible way if we're
going to neutralize this threat solar
sunrise told us that we didn't have time
to slow down we need to keep keep on
moving and fix the things we can fix to
to patch the holes and keep us moving
down the road to information assurance